Most of our audience knows that the year is 2020.
We are one of the richest countries in the world
and there are endless food lines in Texas of
people lining up at a food bank to get food.
More than 6000 cars and twenty five thousand
people lined up to get free food from the North
Texas Food Bank. This is the largest food giveaway
ever by this food bank. Most people in the line
received a turkey, some dry products, bread
and fresh produce. Each person was given
about 20 meals worth of food. According to the
food bank, at least 40 percent of the people
waiting for food were new to that food bank.
And there, because of the virus, there's a
report from the Institute for Policy Research at
Northwestern University from June which reported
that food insecurity has doubled in the United
States and tripled for families with kids as
a result of the pandemic. And when you look at
the pictures and video of this and you realize
this is optional, you have to be asking
questions about why this is going on.
We are not a country with no money and lacking
resources. We throw out a third or more of the
food that we produce. It's even more if you
count all stages of the food production process,
including stuff that's left in the fields, because
it would not be physically attractive enough
to be worth it to send to a grocery store. We have
a president that, in the midst of this pandemic is
just absent. Donald Trump is not taking questions
in weeks. In the time since the election,
he's only been seen three times. Once was
two a.m. on election night, claiming he won.
One was laying a wreath on Veterans Day and one
was taking credit a week ago for coronavirus
vaccines that are upcoming, reportedly without
taking a single question. He's not answered a
single question from the media in weeks. And we
have food lines as the president is gone. He's
played golf twice in the last week, but he's not
spoken to the media in three weeks. Remember when
Donald Trump Jr. talked about how this is America?
We don't have the food lines, the bread lines
like he supposedly saw in supposedly communist
countries. Well, we do have them. He's just wrong.
I guess these I guess the difference is these are
capitalist bread lines rather than communist bread
lines. For all the talk about communist bread
lines. And this will never be a socialist country,
this seems pretty damn dystopian to me. This
is Texas, a capitalist state in the U.S.,
a capitalist country filled the state and the
country with capitalists everywhere. Socialism
and communism are now just euphemisms for anything
Republicans don't like, for the government doing
something. We know that at this point. And by
the way, how many people in the bread lines
were the very people decrying socialist bread
lines along with Donald Trump on Twitter just
months ago? It is Texas, after all. It's as much
a red state as it is a blue state, although it
was close this election, the real socialism
is that the red states and in particular red
counties are regularly bailed out by blue states
and blue counties. Think about this. On average,
red states are dramatically more dependent on the
federal government than blue states. And in fact,
the blue states are subsidizing the red states by
paying in more to the federal government than they
get out. While the red states on average get much
more from the federal government than they pay in.
But then you can go even further. Look at it at
the county level, the counties that Donald Trump
won in the election in the whole country only
contribute to 30 percent of our overall economy.
The counties Joe Biden won contribute 70
percent to the overall economy economy. So
think of those numbers and think of the hypocrisy
of these people talking about self-sufficiency and
pulling yourself up by your bootstraps
and dependance on the government.
It's the red counties and the red states that
overwhelmingly depend on the blue counties and the
blue states. They'll never admit it. They'll never
even understand it. They'll never hear about it.
And yet we have the very same bread lines
that Donald Trump Jr. and others decry
as merely a feature or a bug. I guess depending
on your perspective of so-called socialist and
communist countries. It's pathetic, guys. We have
real problems to solve. And Trump is just missing